good morning millennials
happy friday welcome back to the morning
toast
hey claude i know the answer to this
question but i'm going to ask you anyway
how are you dern it's friday
friday it's so bright in the studio i
never really realized these lights are
very powerful
that's the point of them to be powerful
and to shed light on the situation
and i'm so excited to shed light with
you this morning but i'm just
not here in a spiritual sense
yeah physically of course i'm here how
could you miss me but
emotionally i'm elsewhere i understand
and so where are you
in a hospital emotionally i'm in a
hospital okay so what's going on with
you what's new with you
tell us about how you're feeling nothing
i'm really sick this morning because i'm
such a good sister like that's pretty
much
all you guys need to know like yesterday
was council's birthday and i wanted to
make it a night to remember and so i did
just that
and that's this is the price you pay
yeah when you're such a good sister i
understand
but now you're paying the price and we
hate to see it oh
i am so unwell you guys like usually
when i come hungover on the show it's
like that sweet spot of the hangover
where you're like still drunk
yes and it's like you're kind of like
giddy and then it hits you later
that is not me today
okay but at least you're further through
your hangover like you're closer to
the light i really like your positive
spin i really do
thank you i appreciate the effort you
know when sometimes doing the show it
can be a good distraction sometimes i'll
come on here with
terrible cramps or a migraine 40 minutes
later i'm feeling a little better
i agree but also the show is the thing
that gets me out of bed and for that
like i hate the show today
because you didn't want to get out of
bed no i like
i like almost called and was like i'm
not going to make it like i'm in such
bad shape like
honestly i'm getting an iv right after
this which i'm really hoping is going to
turn things around because i have to
drive to the hamptons like
and i'm like if i think about yeah
for too long i will throw up like dead
serious like
i will so just don't talk about alcohol
okay it wasn't
i wasn't you know like when you're
flashing back to the main like you think
of like the really syrupy
together and you think of like the shot
yeah i did it
this shot where you should have stopped
i knew exactly which one it was and
brian ordered it
like you know what i mean obviously now
you don't want to hear of like good
don't tip tricks but like you have
enough of these experiences which i've
been where you bit
where you've been and like it is the
worst feeling on earth i go out of my
way to avoid it at all because which is
why i get it you're so great
but this is you can still have fun but
like now you know which shot was the one
that did you win right
yeah but see the thing is like i wanted
to take it and like honestly i don't
even know if i regret it like i really
wanted it
in the moment and so like normalize
wanting things in the moment like
okay i wanted it and like normalize
paying the price no i'm not on board
with that
okay well we're here for you we're all
here for you we thank you so much for
showing up
it's friday though we've got to get down
on friday got to
and then you're free as a bird and you
have everything to look forward to this
weekend you're such a good sister so let
the good memories carry you through this
hangover
thank you i will do just that and you
know i actually um
what was i gonna say i um had
drinks with dorinda oh my gosh yes i met
up with her she was having dinner with
brian
and i met up with her and honestly it
was i just was trying to keep up
yeah so good times were had
by all any stories any tea anything you
want to share
no okay like we were at the same table
we like didn't really talk that much you
know
yeah yeah i know how that goes it's just
like a big table you know yeah tables
can be big
i love people actually you know in the
era of it's actually
a tiny in the era of kobe like your
table actually can't be that big sorry
it was actually now that i think about
it
the smallest table like for eight people
it was literally
this because it was like a cocktail
table yeah but you like people kept
joining
chairs and chairs and chairs and i swear
to god the table was this big
hysterical so it actually wasn't a big
table at all damn
well we have a lot to share with you
today and we're gonna get into it before
we let you go for the weekend
school's out for the weekend
[Music]
summer's like here no don't say that i'm
not ready to show my legs
yesterday neither am i but it didn't
stop me
yesterday people thought it was snowing
behind us and then someone
thought it was like bird feathers no
i'll tell you what it was solid pollen
i didn't lie when i said the allergies
came for me this week i saw it when i
was walking into the studio this morning
there's pollen like all over this
air and it would it's it's as if we have
trees and greenery in the city
like if only we got the benefits it's as
if we live in like a lush garden for the
amount of pollen we have
a gray garden so that's what that's
about
but yeah no spring is upon us so if
you're somewhere where the weather is
nice i hope you have a great weekend and
let's
let's usher them into the weekend in
style claude what do you think
we never you've already ushered yourself
into the weekend
i know i literally dug a grave for
myself in the weekend and i honestly
i've such a busy weekend like it's
actually giving me so much anxiety
you're going to start feeling better so
soon you're getting an iv
that is like that is 50
of the recovery i yeah i agree and
but it's just like a long drive and like
i'm gonna get nauseous like i just can't
you'll sit in the front
you'll keep your eyes on the road i'll
give you a nausea pill you'll be okay
i need to really reevaluate where i'm at
after my iv yeah don't worry about what
you can control you know what if push
comes to shove if you need to wait and
go a little later
yeah you'll do that shout out to iv
drips for hooking it up with the iv
last minute we're going to do a live iv
a live v
while she sat here and did the show and
had an iv but they couldn't get here in
time
that would have been iconic iconic maybe
next time because there will definitely
be a next
next time there will certainly be a next
time okay cool maybe next time when you
know that you're going out like i'll
change it for you okay i think without
further ado
where are you where is dew obviously
could not come today
he has a deadbeat mother who drunk again
you know and he woke up and found her on
the couch
and he's just once again making himself
breakfast you know
like that scene in matilda where her
parents like don't care about her but
like she does the laundry and everything
like that is thea this morning
totally and i almost i knew that theo
wasn't gonna make it today i almost
brought brew i would have loved that
i knew you wouldn't but with the iv here
like i didn't want him to like get in
the bag or anything yeah
start sniffing on some zofran yes so i
just figured it was a no pup
sort of day that's the worst kind of day
yeah but
i think brew's gonna make an appearance
sometime soon he's been asking to come
back to work with mom
i would love to see him like so
desperately he's
so sickening like he's stunningly
gorgeous he's so sick it's so twisted
it's
disgusting i love him so dearly me too
are you ready without further ado do you
get into the fast five stories that
you do need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
i am and today's episode is brought to
you by the zebra think about all the
things things you purchased in
quarantine i've got a lot of new
electronics
there was a brief moment with the bean
bag there's just like a lot going on
and after all the purchases this year
there's one of your biggest purchases
of the year insurance americans
overspend on car and home insurance by
billions every year and that's money
that could have spent on more retail
therapy
more bean bags that's where the zebra
can help you the zebra is the nation's
leading insurance comparison site for
car and home insurance
in minutes you can compare policies from
every major provider for free
all in one independent marketplace after
a few quick questions
zebra pairs people with the right
insurance company for them helping
everyone save time and money
you can buy online or over the phone
with one of their licensed insurance
agents
make sure make insurance your smartest
purchase yet visit the zebra.com
toast that's t h e z e b r a
dot com slash t-o-a-s-t
the zebra.com toast love it
okay first story some sad news for you
sorry to make this day
even harder but kim kicking me while i'm
down
kim and kroy's don't be tardy has been
canceled after eight seasons
are you serious bravo has canceled kim
zolciak and cory biermann's real house
as of atlanta spin-off don't be tardy
after
i'm so upset are you serious that's what
page six is reporting an insider told
page six on friday but why it's so
good i don't know
oh my god i'm so upset like i'm
literally on the verge of tears
how could they do this to us question
mark i don't know i feel like for so
long like
we thought it was always like never
coming back and then like it always came
back so we got used to it coming back
oh my god i'm so upset because now like
the biermanns are officially like not on
bravo
yeah in any real way yeah well brielle's
on
sunday for the kids special no but you
know what i mean i'm like a recurring
show
yeah that makes me really sad yeah uh
maybe this means like a kim zolciak
returned to real housewives of atlanta
like i would love that
you never know oh my god i'm devastated
i'm shocked
tmz was the first to report the news of
the show's cancellation which means like
it's legit it's legit
i'm genuinely surprised yeah and
devastated
it's a loss for sure no and their
ratings must be low because like
i didn't even hear that it got cancelled
like you know yeah
but i've also been like in a coma for
the last 12 hours so right so how would
you have known when would i have heard
yeah i'm devastated i'm sorry to do this
to you today no today of all days
it's just one of those shows that like
people
don't watch and they should i unders if
anybody understands that it's me
it is the society of bravo yeah
perhaps but it had eight seasons that's
pretty
respectable yeah i guess and everything
must end at some point and she's
honestly one of the only housewives
who's gotten their own spin-off show
successfully
yeah ever after was canceled yeah better
than getting married
eight season says a lot many of them
else had their own show it's kind of
crazy how like lisa
vader vanderpump rules yeah yeah so like
people don't give kim zolciak
like the credit because she left real
housewives of atlanta in kind of a
disgraceful way
but she really is it's very impressive
she's like one of the only sad story
yeah one of the only housewives to carry
like her own show for eight seasons
that's crazy
yeah and you never know i feel like they
could come back to tv in a different way
like i could see brielle on summer house
that's an amazing idea so let's just put
it out into the universe brielle
on summer house we need brielle on
something yeah remember when brielle
like
went to la to be the next giuliana
rancic like on the show yeah i'm like oh
my god girl like that's what everyone
wants to do get in line
i know but she has like a good chance if
anybody could do it it would have been
her that's true but then she didn't do
it and then julianna ransack like never
left you know
yeah you're gonna have to take that job
from her cold dead fingers
yes did you watch any more bold type
yesterday i did i watched a few episodes
um i'm just like i'm such a sun
you know i mean i know and i literally
called jackie like
10 minutes into the first episode i was
like i do not like sutton she was like
you're wrong just wait
boy was i wrong she's the only one with
a good hand on her shoulders jane
i can't yeah i literally can't like with
the worst like okay there's layoffs
coming
and they can't tell anyone that there's
laughs coming but jaclyn gave
jane a heads up and was like you need to
start writing about [ __ ] people actually
want to read about like great you're
passionate about politics nobody [ __ ]
cares
right about you know ass facials you
know and she's like
ignoring jacqueline's advice you know
she's like no i'll find my niche
and it's like we know layoffs it's
coming it's like you dumb [ __ ] like
this woman tried to
warn you and of course she didn't end up
getting laid off but dead ass that's bad
business because she should have got
laid off
she's a liability to this company yeah
and so reckless when that
stripper sued her and then like going to
the woman's place of work against her
legal counsel
who was richard by the way like the
dumbest [ __ ] ever
yeah just wait just wait she she has her
moment of what
of justice like where she finally like
where i feel like she finally like
learns her lesson yes central learned
her lesson okay i'm so excited yeah but
i don't want to over hype it it was like
how i read it
um but speaking of the shows being
cancelled
hillary duff is speaking out on why
adult lizzie mcguire revival was
axed this is like the drama nobody
asked for like she got us all hyped up
and also crushed our dreams never told
us why and honestly i don't even give a
[ __ ] anymore like you could take that
stupid reboot
and shove it up your hair yeah hairy ass
it smells iconic line for me girls i
wish regina got to finish it you know
but then she got hit by a buzz
yeah lizzy sent disney into a tizzy that
seems to be the message from hilary duff
regarding the cancellation of the
revival
of her iconic early 2000s show lizzie
mcguire
she said i think they're really trying
to figure out what kind of content they
want living on disney plus
and that doesn't totally align with like
where i see lizzy right now she said
during an appearance on the jess
kegels show on thursday she said i was a
very rough last name
kegel she said i was very protective of
her and they're very protective of her
so they had different ideas of what it
meant to protect lizzie
she said the one thing for me was just
the way that she could connect with what
was going on
in people that were watching the show
and so for me it only makes sense to
shoot a show where she's acting like a
30 year old in a modern world wait i'm
dying that like all these people these
adults
are fighting about protecting a
fictional character
about protecting lizzie no literally i
need
a memoir protecting lizzy like it sounds
like iconic
here's the thing i'm sure hillary wanted
like lizzy you know trying ecstasy like
no lizzy being kelsey from younger yes
yes
yeah yes and disney they're like we're
not gonna take this
nice girl and make her into a
provocateur
yeah and honestly i would
they reboot such [ __ ] these days it's
like this one actually would be like
fine no
i'm so glad this reboot didn't get off
the ground every time a reboot doesn't
happen like
i am happy
i'm an anti-reboot we could have been
born like whenever you know
but we decide well we didn't decide we
just happened to be born in the reboot
era and like for that i'm annoyed
no same like where i want to be alive in
the original content era
100 and then it's like all these reboots
and i know i sound like a broken clock
or whatever the all these reboots in the
paparazzi where i did
this funeral
[Laughter]
that is not what i was gonna say i don't
even know
oh all these reboots and no season two
of the society like that's what i was
gonna say but yours was better right but
that's
that's what happens when we get original
content like i don't know maybe they ran
out of ideas like
i can feel that because i don't know
where they were taking it i don't even
think they knew where they were taking
this i don't know either they had like
the pied piper like
on the wall and then the children and
the dog the dog who was like
transcending universes yeah from one
universe where were they taking it no
[ __ ] i think they got canceled
because they didn't know
no they literally could not come up with
an ending because it was so
it's it's really lost why
does lost spoiler alert do they end up
in it like they were in an alternate
universe
so this is be giving people time if they
want to watch it the
ending was very um
ambiguous and you were really meant to
interpret it yourself which was really
[ __ ] annoying
but the whole thing was that like the
entire journey in the lost uh
in the island was some sort of purgatory
some sort of waiting room for the
afterlife like they had all died in the
crash
oh i think i've done extensive research
nobody knows not even the people who
wrote the show they don't know like they
like want to leave it open
yeah because they couldn't it was
honestly one of the it's regarded as one
of the worst endings like of
tv history which i do agree with but
what would you have liked to see happen
they get rescued
no the thing is is that like the second
that the island became like
voodoo monster like
witchcraft they were never gonna get
rescued because like this was like a
fake island that never existed on any
real like
airplane radar so what i would have
liked for hap for to happen
is
they got off the island at one point and
then they went back like
where did they go home no they got off
the island they had this
it took four seasons and all of them got
off except
one girl who like went crazy and like
wanted to be one of the
wildlings you know and they're like we
have to go back for claire
and he was like i have to go back
there's something i have to do like
everyone had their own reason for
wanting to go back
i tell you when these [ __ ] morons
went back to the island i was like i'm
done with this show
yeah but then it's like it was an
alternate universe so like it doesn't
even matter i don't know
yeah that's how i feel about money heist
they like got away
spoiler with the first heist and they
all were like living they like rob the
bank they had like so much money they
all went into their
own corners of the world to hide out and
live
with the money but like these two people
that were in a couple who are so goddamn
annoying they like broke up after a few
years
so the guy like left the island that
they were at and he got like tracked on
the way and they they caught him
he went to jail well not even jail like
a torture chamber and
in order to get him out they went into
another bank and did the same thing
again
no no like the decision-making skills of
the characters in certain tv shows is so
dumb and frustrating it could kill a
woman no and also
what's so crazy is in this second heist
like someone else one of the other
members of the squad dies
spoiler alert i think it was nairobi if
i remember and like
he she died so that like he could get
out of jail for
mistakes that he made like jesus died
for our sins nairobi died for his sins
stop um before we continue i just want
to let everyone know that today's
episode is also brought to you by jinx
an online dog wellness brand that offers
nutrient-rich all-natural clean kibble
meal toppers
treats and dental chews delivering
balance nutrition in every bite that
arrives directly to your door
after all dogs have evolved from their
wolf-like ancestors they are 21st
century omnivores that require both meat
and plant-based nutrients
which better suit their lifestyle than
include a lot more sleeping and a lot
less hunting
so jinx offers a complete all-natural
nutrition solution for your pup
premium clean label kibble that is
powder powered by superfood backed by
science
it is full with lean proteins 20 plus
superfoods and a patented probiotic
it is a limited ingredient treats they
also offer limited ingredient treats um
with superfoods so they really have you
covered from start to finish
uh the website is thinkjinx.com and
instagram is also thinkjinx.com
um and if you use code toast50 on the
website thinkjinx.com
you can get 50 off your first order so
that's toast50
at thinkjinx.com love it
okay claudia your iv has arrived would
you like to stop the stream we'll start
a new one
no and plug you in no i think we should
just like do it like a live
iv are you open to um we're live right
now
are you open to doing it while we're
live like i wouldn't mind doing it
yeah and you could like sit right next
to me you can introduce yourself
let's set up the bike let's give her a
mic i am just like i'm so
you have wha no you look stunning
you can say no if you want to also but
we're gonna have fun
come join that is so funny i'm so
excited for you
i'm so excited about she's got a big
suitcase with lots of
life-saving medicines like it's going to
be great what's in that suitcase is
you want to get one too change your life
maybe you go first okay
you first no i'm like i love an i have
been obsessed
with ivs no it's once you start you just
can't stop
you just can't stop and one time i did
do a preemptive iv so i got one like
when we were at stagecoach one year i
got one before the first day
that way the whole weekend i was super
hydrated so even though i was drinking
smart
it was a beautiful thing so i got one
last week and i think i honestly would
be in worse shape
today like i've gotten one now two weeks
into where i'm starting to do it like a
weekly thing
right because that's more water than
like you ever drank in my life and
that's really why i like ivs because i
have a really hard time
drinking getting the water down like
this is me this morning like it's right
here
i need to do a motivational water gallon
today i don't do it every day
it's so much work it's so much work and
yesterday i was like back to back all
day i was barely in my house it was like
a real day
pre-march 2020 and so i wouldn't i could
the
bottle's too big and heavy i can't walk
around with it so
i wouldn't have been able to drink it
all day but today i'm gonna like i have
i'm making a to-do list today except so
many like small you're making a list and
checking it twice
yep i'm gonna find out who's nadia nice
because i have so many small things to
do like returns
emails to respond to i need to get close
for our trip next week
i need to make a to-do list and then i'm
gonna start checking it off like i'm
actually really excited i think today's
gonna be a productive we're just having
like
two totally different days no i know but
now that your iv is here like i don't
feel bad talking about productivity no
no i'm so i already feel better like and
i didn't even get anything injected like
the idea of it it's the idea of it
um well we can keep going with the show
okay do you want are you ready for our
next story
yeah because sex in the city smith jared
has
not been asked back everyone this is
marisol hi marisol
thank you so much for coming on short
notice i'm so grateful for you and it's
also nurse appreciation week so
give it up for marisol yay
so i have a little bruise here from i
got an iv last week i just wanted to i
don't know if that's bad or anything
yeah yeah do your elbow you know
actually i very frail veins because i'm
so skinny
um so i've heard that i have a hard time
finding veins in my
elbow but you let me know we could also
switch seats if you need to do your
other hand
we'll get there but i think we're fine
i'm so veiny like i'm
ready for an idea at all times
yeah like let's just shoot it up like
chat and drift
chat we're talking about sex in the city
what's the t smith jared has not been
asked back for the reboot
yeah why i don't know sex and the city
star jason lewis who played samantha's
young model
beau smith jared different from
boyfriend businessman
zambo hasn't been asked back to hbo for
the reboot he said very upsetting i have
not but i would be the last to know he
told the daily front row as much as i
appreciate the flattery the conversation
is about the girls
he's just the latest in the series mail
love interests who aren't coming back in
february page six exclusively reported
that chris noth who played mr big had
not been approached for the reboot
either
that's weird that he hadn't been
approached mr b yeah i know we talked
about the announcement no but like i
thought if big wasn't coming back it's
because chris snoth was like busy with
other projects oh like he turned it down
yeah they turned him down
right agreed that's crazy like he is
the show 100 so i mean we already talked
about why he probably won't be back and
they're probably gonna spoiler kill him
off
um so that carrie can go back to being
like annoying as [ __ ] and running around
um and aiden's coming back he is right
i don't know why i thought i heard that
i feel like this is like an alternate
ending to sex and the city like yeah
carrie wants her cake and wants to eat
it too
yeah she wants to have her cake and eat
it too she's disgusting i literally
can't stand her
and i mean smith jared not coming back
makes a little bit of sense because he
was holding samantha back
but yes it would have been nice to have
him come back in like a friend capacity
broken up yeah they're broken up but
like he was they could still be friends
agreed to normalize being friends with
your ex right especially if you're
samantha and like you just have
so much like love in your heart yeah
friendship to give yeah
so it would have been nice to see him
because he was just a good character
agreed
but at least like my personal
non-negotiables are coming back
up how the iv is in
if you have needle phobia this might not
be the episode for you
i have needle phobia do you no no if you
did you wouldn't be
calling an iv every week no literally um
what was it oh we're in okay
wow this is crazy like modern technology
yeah
no like nothing's gonna stop you from
doing your show
no literally so
wow so what is in the pack
right let's see it
oh wow this is really like a legit
operation tonight i'm just not gonna
look you know
yeah i'll distract you i'll let you know
if there's anything you should know
so who aside from the four girls do you
need to see in the reboot
oh good question um steve
no i love steve no harry period harry
period
magda has passed away oh my god which is
really sad because she was like
honey and
who else they i'm saying like the worst
characters like oh uh stanford
and uh i can live with that anthony i
could live without him
you could live without him i mean he's
definitely a bonus but i'm just glad
charlotte and harry are still together
well we don't even know that but
hopefully if they're not then the show
does no but it's like they're deciding
to ruin the show like literally do
everything possible
to make it the worst possible thing
where's the pack it's cool it's coming
oh the package i just got my needle
ready i'm just like
me and my veins are so you're still
playing hard to get you're so vascular
i'm so vascular feeling so vascular
today
um okay ready for our next story yeah
because it's
again about true love sort of real
housewives of new jersey's dolores
catania reacts to her ex frank calling
himself her soul mate
on watch what happens live which was
such a sweet moment she said
safe to say i agree dolores is not
denying that her ex-husband frank is her
soul mate
on wednesday and watch what happens live
he declared that even though we're not
romantically involved i'm still her soul
mate
dolores reacted to the comment while
speaking with e news agreeing that
they've bonded for a long time though
she doesn't expect they'll be
re-entering a romantic relationship
again it's too bad
she said safe to say i agree with him
you know a soulmate i don't think has to
be an intimate relationship a soulmate
can be a dog
a soulmate can be a child yes like
cameron and louie no i'm gonna cry by
the way because this is literally that
seed in the sexes in the city
what if charlotte's so sweet and she was
like what if we were each other's
soulmates and all the women like are
trying not to laugh at her like but it
was really sweet
yeah or a best friend and frank is
definitely my soul mate in the fact that
i've done
past life things and it says me and
frank have been bonded for a long time
together so i could see that
so this actually like feels to me so
complete because sure and no and the
psychic said that david wasn't her soul
mate
and that doesn't mean that her soul mate
is out there and she needs to go find it
right
frank is her soul mate and david's just
is her man's
100 and so to me this makes the whole
situation
even more beautiful blended and
i love it that's actually a really good
call and
it all makes sense like this is the
puzzle piece to like figure out like why
did this
the psychic say that it wasn't no like
and you know what like not every person
is gonna be your soulmate like
some some people just are comfortable
together and i think what delores has
is a really really nice life a really
really nice life i think she sees it
that way too
and if i was dolores and i was in my 50s
and that was my life i would be so happy
yeah i so agree cool it's the season of
dolores
a hundred percent are you ready for our
fifth and final story
is it brought to you by hair food i just
have a lot going on over here do you
yeah i didn't notice it is brought to
you by hair food and by the way i'm
obsessed with hair food also like i love
when i get to do the reads
do you yes not because i don't do them
every day like can be fun
oh you switch things up i don't like
doing the stories hair food offers
simple
super food inspired products that will
make your hair look and feel
amazing whatever hair texture or hair
type you have
hair food has a recipe for you in
addition to their beloved nourishing
coconut milk and chai spice collection
you've got to try some of their new
recipes the apple
apple cider vinegar hair rinse is
perfect for daisy this one when your
hair needs a gentle cleanse before
conditioning
no shampoo needed the tumeric and almond
oil detangling milk takes care of the
most stubborn knots and reduces frizz
that was pretty good too and the shea
butter and pear color repair concentrate
makes
over-processed hair look vibrant and
healthy and they all smell so good you
guys this ad read
is making me hungry literally also this
is literally a wellness retreat for your
hair
yeah every hair food product is free of
sulfates paraben dyes mineral oils and
is certified
pita cruelty free we love to see it we
love hair food we take pride in our very
shiny hair so we are always
my shiny hair and me
my shiny teeth and me so we are always
looking for products our hair can digest
ingest
in order to be more beautiful stunning
and smart and hair food is the product
for us the apple cider vinegar rinse
is amazing sometimes your hair needs a
cleanse and apple cider vinegar has so
many like good benefits
for hair and hair growth hair
stimulating the roots like there's so
many the fact that there's like a legit
product with it is amazing and it really
is
very a very very good product apple
cider vinegar is one of those
ingredients that like
transforms so many different areas of
your life in your body so like imagine
what it does for your hair you don't
have to imagine anymore
with hair food so if you're looking for
nourished healthy hair
it's got to be hair food look for it at
amazon walmart and target
that's hair food everything of the sort
take our word for it
we love it how'd i do excellent i'm very
impressed
thanks okay now you look ready for our
fifth and final story
do i twitter is launching a tip jar to
let you send money to your favorite
tweeters
great twitter has soft launched tip jar
a new feature to make it easier for
power users to earn money from their
followers starting on thursday anyone
using twitter and english
can send tips using the ios and android
app to eligible accounts
on twitter's android app users can also
send tips from within the spaces live
audio chat feature oh do they have a
clubhouse like
yes everyone does i think facebook's
getting one too called spaces
i don't know i think that's twitter
spaces yes sorry i was listening
i'm being just being honest no that's
fine you have an arm a needle in your
arm
for now twitter has enabled tip jar for
a limited group of people who use
twitter and english
which includes creators journalists
experts and non-profit organizations
twitter plans great i can't wait to hear
from my favorite journalists
can't wait to tip them twitter plans to
widen the role out of tip jar to more
people and to expand it to more
languages twitter is not taking any cut
of tip jar that's good but honestly like
twitter needs to
stop what they're doing like immediately
just truly give up and go home twitter
freeze yeah like stop all these new
innovations first of all
you look like a clown like no one cares
and second of all like
just stop like you're embarrassing
yourself go home i'm not here for this
in any
way shape or form um but you know it's
not those it's not like it's being
forced upon anyone if you want to tip
your favorite creators on twitter i
guess you can go and do that
yeah the whole concept of tipping seems
bizarre for
creators because it feels like for the
most part like you should really just
like
it's a service like you should receive
content in exchange for money
i guess the content is like this fire
tweet oh great yeah
there's so many so many of them but you
know when like if someone's tweet goes
viral someone who's not a public person
yes they either experience something
funny or had a funny thought whatever
and it goes viral and then
beneath it they'll be like check out my
soundcloud whatever it is but now it
could be like
you could be tipped for that that is a
very very good call because
people who go viral make so much content
for news outlets and
all these other like companies meme
pages like but they themselves make no
money from it
yeah from viral moments so it could be a
good feature for that okay the iv
is right out of the bag well no it's in
the bag
of course because i know it's water
everywhere there was a spillage
sorry that was really confusing no
you're getting ready the idea is out of
the bag that it came in
still in its bag and i think the zofran
is getting lit up
the iv bag looks like when you get a
fish at the fair yeah and they put a
fish in the goldfish in a bag
yeah that's a good call but then you
grow up and instead it's electrolytes
and zofran
that is literally like the most water i
have ever drank it's like the biggest
thing
that's more water than you drink in a
month probably yeah but if you include
lacroix
oh well if i include lacroix biermann
[Laughter]
can we talk a little bit about tv recap
because yeah i did not watch kardashians
but i did watch summer house recap part
two and it was
when did you find the time seriously
i got a screener okay good because
otherwise like i didn't even watch
kardashians right
oh you didn't no i got home from dinner
so late i finished my book last night
not to me not to like go into my thing
but it was
such a good book called the american
heiress by um
daisy goodwin if you're into downton
abbey it's this book like literally
it was so good it was so good enjoy it
okay that's my endorsement oh
it was just like kind of boring i really
feel like they didn't need a part two um
everyone was just like really
like bullying hannah and even though
like i don't agree with most of hannah's
decisions like
you did end up feeling bad for her like
everyone was just like on her like even
towards the end she like tried to
apologize and
i just don't think she's like the most
sincere person in the world especially
with her apologies
and they were just like she was just
trying towards the end and they were
like
oh you're so fake like in the middle of
her apology when she's just like
literally been on an apology tour like
this reunion
um it is really sad to see the
dissolution of her and amanda's
friendship i will say that
and luke like kind of said like the most
[ __ ] up thing ever and hannah walked
away and started crying
because basically the whole premise is
that like for the past couple summers
luke and hannah like have had this thing
and then this summer like hannah came in
like ready to date him and stuff they've
been talking all winter
and he acts like he never met her and he
is like he is kind of gaslighting her
she definitely is into him more than
he's into her but he's acting like
nothing ever happened
and while this is happening is she
already in her new relationship no but
she literally goes to jazz like kind of
as like a
rebound but ends up falling in love okay
so he did her favor but like the whole
season was just like will they won't
they who's telling the truth
here she comes and i really feel like
yeah we can start and hit it up
so it's a little yellow
that's the vitamin b complex
zinc oh i love zing love zinc that's
actually great for using
yeah why it's just like a great uh like
for me specifically no no for oneself
oh my god i can't wait to just get
started like and be done you know
yeah when i would have an iv i'd like be
laying and then i would
slowly be able to rise sometimes it
stings
it slows down okay i'll let you know
sometimes it stinks
stings like if it is going too fast into
your arm i think got it
okay but i'm feeling something drip drip
i gotta take a picture of this
yeah of course seriously i'll get in it
smile
um she's she's busy okay well that's
good too
what a [ __ ] show no literally but this
is so us
this is so us i'm surprised this is the
first time this has happened i am
what i was going to say about
summerhouse is that he ended up
basically just saying like
hannah was like i'm confused like you
invited me out to minnesota to meet your
family like
what you you've just been like lying
this whole time
and he basically was like i never wanted
to take you to minnesota production
asked me to
and that's why hannah like stormed off
and cried are we going now we're ready
for the picture okay let's take a
picture okay
so cute um i'm so excited to be doing
this
so for the most part it i mean it was a
good season but the second part of
summer house was not great wait go to
claudia's solo
look at this you guys this is literally
the best thing i've ever done she had
ivs every week on the toast
every friday just to get us on the right
foot for the weekend
um so that's right no that's okay i'm
just trying to get through it
it was honestly a boring episode it was
the first time i ever felt like part one
if the reunion was more interesting than
part two
oh i don't think they needed a part two
very cool i mean everyone was talking
about it i'm still gonna try and catch
up the only thing that i saw that i felt
like i needed to comment on was paige's
dress which was so [ __ ] sickening so
[ __ ] sickening
that i might have to go and find it you
should go find it ariana grande wore it
she looked so good
when i saw a picture of it i didn't like
die for it but it was a perfect reunion
dress because she shot from
from the waist up and she just looked
like so stunning beautiful and smart
and like i just live for her she's
really such like an iconic
reality star who never gets involved in
drama especially because this season is
like her two best friends and she just
wants
no part of it oh but that's like that
works for everyone yeah like
that andy was like why won't you take a
side like
because if she did take a side hannah
really is her best friend they have a
podcast together but like amanda is also
she's gonna be a bridesmaid in amanda's
wedding so it's like
and you know what eventually like hannah
and amanda will figure it out because
like that's how the reality
tides turn and then paige is like left
holding the iv back
unless hannah gets fired or doesn't come
back to the show
oh yeah but it seems like she's like the
center of the
of course like there would be i don't
even know what i would be talking about
if it weren't for hannah so
there's value in that yeah and she also
does chat room and stuff so bravo
yeah yeah so it was boring but um i
really enjoyed becoming a summer house
stan this year i wish i got on earlier
but you know
people try like have been trying to tell
us for sure for so long and i refuse to
listen i'm just like i'm so busy
unless brian kelly tells you to do it
and that's who told me to do it yeah
then you won't then you can't hear it
so you don't watch kardashians no i
didn't because i wanted to catch up on
the last
few episodes and we got home like late
last night from dinner or dinner and i
wanted to finish my book and i knew you
weren't going to watch it so i was like
get the night off um but that's what
apparently it was like emotional because
it was the one where they tell the cast
and crew oh i actually would enjoy that
i think
yeah no same i just wanted to like watch
it in my own time
that is our show i'm so glad that you
i'm so glad this worked out we like love
a [ __ ] show
like panicky woman here we do it's been
a while i'm all
i'm honestly already feeling better from
the show if you watch the beginning
where you
couldn't even say the word thank you no
i i could say now tequila i actually
feel like
look at that a full recovery if that's
not a stunning endorsement for iv drips
oh yeah check out iv drips you guys
killer service killer service will bring
will bring you back from the dead look
at me now look at me now
yep that there's no other endorsement
that you need other than watching this
episode
yeah um that's our show you guys thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasting we found the spotify to
stitch your public video i read a cat
box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning toast and leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are
thank you guys for a great week of shows
and a great week of
being alive totally we will see you on
monday have an amazing weekend goodbye